4 3 2 1
françois mitterrand est élu président de
la république
[Musique]
51,7 %
voilà donc l'image de ce nouveau
président de la république françois
mitterrand vient d'être réélu
vous voyez donc jacques chirac 19 9%
jean-marie le pen
17,9 pour cent et lionel jospin 16,1
j'assume pleinement la responsabilité de
cet échec et j'en tire les conclusions
en me retirant de la vie politique après
[Applaudissements]
après la fin de l'élection
présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
ségolène royal est donc j'assume
pour nicolas sarkozy 47 bien sûr pour
ségolène royal troisième présidentielle
perdue après 95 et l'absence au deuxième
tour en 2002 ça fait beaucoup c'est
françois hollande qui est élu président
de la république avec
51,9 % des froids la côte est depuis
longtemps depuis longtemps mais je suis
content sarkozy semble assez génial
6,4 pour cent pour benoît hamon jamais
candidat socialiste n'était tombé aussi
bas la benoît hamon c'est le score du ps
et des verts 1 6 4 1 à ce moment là
puisqu'il ya une une candidature commune
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire moi je pense
d'abord la fidélité à son histoire à ses
valeurs ce qui veut pas dire les
solutions du passé mais quand même la
fidélité ce que je porte dans cette
élection présidentielle c'est héritage
de cette gauche républicaine européenne
social socialiste qui a fait siennes les
questions d'écologie et qui veut
gouverner et transformer le monde et
améliorer la vie des françaises et des
français je pense qu'on est encore dans
le tumulte la difficulté évidemment on
l'a vu il n'a pas été possible de se
rassembler avec la gauche des
discussions ont eu lieu mais elles n'ont
pas abouti
je pense que cette élection là est une
élection qui s'inscrit dans quelque
chose encore de très difficile et je
porte je porte cette cette campagne dans
ce contexte avec beaucoup de lucidité
mais je sais que ce que nous sommes en
train de faire aujourd'hui va nous
permettre de construire quelque chose
parce que ce que nous portons c'est la
voix d'une gauche qui a toujours été
présente dans la république et quand
elle n'est pas présente dans la
république elle a toujours été là pour
les grandes conquêtes les grandes
avancées le monde politique et
médiatique a beaucoup changé ces
dernières années mais pour autant je
pense et je porte cette ce message là
les classes moyennes les catégories
populaires qui aujourd'hui souffrent
d'une injustice sociale terrible parce
que nous sommes dans un pays où il ya
beaucoup trop d'injustice où
il risque d'y en avoir encore plus parce
que les projets que je vois
sur la retraite les projets que je vois
sur le démantèlement de l'école sont des
choses qui vont encore affaiblir ce qui
fait pour moi la force de la france
c'est-à-dire risque des services publics
de faim risque de disparition du peu je
crois qu'il y aurait eu un risque de
disparition si le ps n'avait pas été
enfin si cette gauche républicaine
sociale et européennes n'avaient pas été
présente dans cette élection elle est là
beaucoup de femmes et d'hommes me disent
bien sûr que c'est difficile on est
présent dans les territoires un très
présent dans les territoires puisque si
vous regardez la carte électorale dans
les communes les départements ou les
régions le ps pèse environ 15% mais
c'est vrai que du local au national
on n'a pas encore réussi à faire
complètement cette mutation elle
nécessitait et elle nécessite cette
présence aujourd'hui dans cette élection
très très difficile très particulière de
2022 pour permettre justement d'ouvrir
une nouvelle page en tous les cas de
façon très lucide très responsable très
consciente de la difficulté de la tâche
dans laquelle avec d'autres je me suis
lancée que cette difficulté de tâches
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui est
celle qui doit permettre d'ouvrir un
nouvel espace à ce que j'appelle cette
gauche républicaine européenne
qui a intégré l'écologie et vous savez
la gauche dans notre pays ne gagne
jamais par les extrêmes elle ne gagne
jamais ni par le témoignage ou
l'exclusive protestation elle gagne
lorsqu'elle a envie de gouverner
lorsqu'elle s'inscrit aussi dans
l'histoire du pays dans ce qui fait
notre république je suis une
républicaine vraiment absolue pour moi
la république elle est aussi laïque elle
est laïque et sociale c'est l'un et
l'autre c'est pas l'un sans l'autre et
c'est ce que nous devons porter ce que
je porte dans cette campagne mais ce que
je vais porter et vous verrez qu'au
lendemain aussi de cette élection quel
qu'en soit le résultat
beaucoup beaucoup d'initiatives vont se
déployer sur le territoire en france en
lien avec nos amis les sociaux
démocrates qui gouvernent partout
ailleurs dans beaucoup de pays européens
pour reconstruire cette proposition
absolument indispensable et dans les
autres pays je pense l'espagne je pense
le portugal ou d'autres il a fallu
parfois dix ans voire plus de 10 ans
pour pouvoir reconstruire cette offre
politique là et bien c'est le travail
auquel je me suis attelé dès cette
campagne présidentielle
[Musique]